hey guys it's mkbhd welcome back to
another HD video now if I've ever gotten
close to doing a retro review video this
is probably the closest I've ever gotten
to doing one and if this video does get
800 likes I'll actually be giving one
away you're looking at the review of the
phone that started it all the
revolutionary device the one that
Android fans like me really identified
themselves by when Android first gained
that identity and that's the original
Motorola Droid you can watch my original
review by clicking the Cheerios and
again like I said if you liked the video
and unlocked Motorola Droid will be
given away so giveaway details are
always on Twitter without any further
ado let's go ahead and take it to the
granddaddy of the all devices that I
think are making their way up on the
Verizon platform right now let's go
ahead and check out the original
Motorola Droid if you've been an mkbhd
viewer for long enough you've watched my
original Motorola Droid review two years
ago back at the end of 2009 and this was
the biggest baddest new Android phone
out there and if you didn't already know
this has been my on contract phone ever
since then I take really good care of my
gadgets and my phone is no exception
so while this does look beat up keep in
mind this is two years of usage that's
gone into this device that being said
one of the best parts of the Droid is
that it is all metal this phone has been
dropped opened and closed hundreds of
times slid across surfaces and you know
had more than its share of beating up
and it's more than held itself together
without a single replacement battery
life as we can expect has degraded
slightly but that's not stopping me from
getting a full day of use out of it
you'll see a bit of my secret for
battery life at the end of this video
but overall it hasn't been the least bit
disappointing to a person who uses their
phone really often like I do and as you
know the Droid is a slider
I've been holding out for the Nexus
Prime which won't have a keyboard but I
occasionally use the crap out of this
keyboard for long messages and emails
and stuff and I'm as you can see I'm
pretty good with it too
this keyboard started off really flat
and two years later it feels even
flatter just like a touchscreen
I'm sure oh gee droid users are
definitely ready to make the transaction
with me to an all touchscreen phone and
again that should probably be the Nexus
Prime but overall everything else about
the Droid is still it's fat grandpa self
it has that rugged rubberized feel in
the hand and feels good
no matter
really what orientation you use it in
now I promise to show you the software
mods I'm using to make this my daily
driver so let's go ahead and take a look
at that first of all I'm using a custom
ROM and this is the simply stunning
gingerbread ROM and it's running on an
ultra-low voltage
1.25 gigahertz kernel yes that's 1.25
gigahertz on it's single core I use an
app called set CPU to manage that keep
the timings just right and when the
droid screen is off it actually under
clocks way down to just 125 megahertz
saving a ton of battery life and another
question I get about the droid a lot is
is it slow well not at one point two
five gigahertz it's not but I'm using a
home screen replacement called launcher
Pro Plus and as I'm about to show you
here this ROM is based off of the latest
version of Android 2.3.4 so this phone
is actually liquid fast so here's the
ROM info and the OS version and
everything and you can see it flies
through the menus as you'd expect from a
1.25 gigahertz processor speed the one
reason it still feels like an OG droid
is the ram it doesn't have nearly as
much RAM as the other zippy phones out
there so apps don't stay loaded in
memory as long and now don't get me
wrong some apps still are quick to open
but as you can see here typically it's
up to the processor to do the work and
just like the rest of my desk setup and
office setup here in my dorm room I have
relatively minimalist style so I keep
the applications I use and need and only
the applications I use in need nothing
no extra parts in this machine this is
how you keep a phone running smooth and
fast for a long long time so there you
have it it's been 2 years with the
Motorola Droid and you've just finished
watching my first retro review video
leave a thumbs up for a chance to win
and let me know what do you think of my
droid setup either way thanks for
watching and be sure to subscribe if you
enjoyed this video
mkbhd signing out peace
you